si la couche et des vidéos de bagarres
comme celle ci j'en ai vu défiler
plusieurs sur des comptes instagram au
télégramme la femme ait tenu des
bourroches moins people une pêche moins
tôt j'ai contacté la plupart de ses
comptes pour comprendre ce phénomène de
combats de rue et pourquoi les personnes
qui tiennent ces comptes les mettez en
ligne tous ont refusé de me rencontrer
pour une interview seule une personne a
accepté de me répondre par téléphone et
de manière anonyme plus
jeune
ça me paraît important de mettre en
garde sur les dangers de tels contenus
et c'est pour ça que dans cette vidéo
j'ai décidé de vous parler de l'histoire
des mânes hermans un jeune boxeur de 15
ans qui vivait à bon dié et après
plusieurs bagarres et des altercations
film et il est tué par le grand frère
d'un de ses amis en février 2021 avec
hugo bayard dit on a essayé de retracer
l'escaladé de la violence qui a mené à
la main un
[Musique]
peu
la première fois les joueurs rentrent
iman c'était forum des associations
j'ai mis une paire de gants et a tapé un
peu dans mes pattes d'ours et
d'éthique
je l'avais dit si tu es sérieux je te
mettrai en compétition si tu travailles
bien et puis dès le début mai avec lui
m'a dit coach veut faire la compétition
je fais de la compétition je je je vais
être champion du monde
[Applaudissements]
sa première compétition c'était les
championnats d'île de france ça faisait
pas très longtemps que celles de la
beauce
j'ai vu aymen commence à faire son
chemin et j'ai dit bon
t'as faim tu en veux il en prenait mais
d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
et ils ont levé de bradl de aymen
ça m'a fait un missile en choeur on a
fait ça m'a fait tout bizarre et après
je regardais sa grand mère j'ai regardé
ses parents un petit peu tard et qui
était son papa qui était vachement fier
j'étais a même étonné de voir son fils
champion d'île de france je me cache pas
j'ai pleuré quand il a gagné la médaille
de médaille d'or et il s'est qualifié
pour les championnats de france mais
c'est toujours même même nous il nous
dit voilà un jour j'y serai champion je
sois champion quoi il m'a demandé de
lâcheté pas mal de trucs pour faire la
boxe même à la maison pour l'entraîner
tout ça quoi et là j'ai compris que
franchement il est dedans quoi
ça sert à faire du box
orange ici ça si on est là c'est signé
il a acheté sa et la firme de
l'entraînement avec pas plus
donc voilà de matrix
franchement elle est il est adorable
quoi
était plein d'imagés quoi c'était comme
intérêt pourquoi les bijoux et bouge et
fait des blagues même à la maison
c'est comme emile acteurs quoi c'était
toujours j'ai le but c'est d'attirer
leur attention vers lui quoi à force de
gagner des combats de boxe thaï et prend
confiance et lui arrive de participer à
des combats de refilmer et sa ses
parents et ses proches n'en savait rien
dans ces vidéos on voit mails et
d'autres jeunes se battent
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui l'aï même
jamais entendu parler de ces combats
sauvage
moi même si j'aurais été au courant je
serais intervenu c'est du n'importe quoi
parce que sur un ring et anar mythes et
des règles et des codes et de l'allée
des valeurs basses et c'est tout
l'inversé de ce qu'on a
[Musique]
on salue
tout d'abord bonjour à tous
merci d'être au rendez vous franchement
ça fait plaisir de vous revoir c'est je
pense que moi et puis les coaches ça
nous fait ça fait énormément plaisir
tout le monde sait ce qui s'est passé
avec humaine
voilà je trouve pas les mots mais bon ça
nous a beaucoup touché je sais c'est un
membre de leur va dire de notre famille
un jour elle me propose à ses amis qu'on
appellera sofiane de le suivre au club
sofiane à 2 ans + caimanes et il
commence à prendre des cours de boxe
thaï lui aussi
à la base il s'entendait bien c'était
des bons copains et il faisait toutes
leurs sorties ensemble et après du jour
au lendemain et problème l'altercation à
la boxe et c'est parti de là
c'est ce qui m'avait dit voilà je tapais
on s'amuse à taper de plus en plus fort
je lui ai fait mal il a mal pris la
chose plantez des rivalités entre entre
élèves et que ça se passe pendant
l'entraînement
on va prendre les deux élèves qu'on les
amène à soi et puis en général than you
stop on parle plus
cela me sert la main
sait-on des gens ça passe vite il ya eu
des temps un échange où il ya un cap et
un peu plus fort et puis après la boxe
ea se chamaillent d'athus ce champ et
puis après derrière il ya les réseaux
sociaux les gens filmés puis ça attise
la violence folle et
les bagarres qui les opposent sont
filmés et partagé a bondi et le grand
frère de seufyann finit par s'emmêler la
première application chez qualité ici
son frère il est venu devant le gymnase
et la voulait régler ses comptes du
grand là il est venu voir aymen est en
fait pour défendre son frère il y avait
dix adultes à côté autour de lui et en
fait humaine il a tapé le grand frère
quand il a tapé le grand frère de 27 ans
et lui l'a pas accepté un trafiquant de
drogue qui se porte comme un patron m'a
fait ça comme un grand il l'a tapé
devant les adultes et sethi lui silence
de tenir sa réputation de
voilà je fais peur je suis quelqu'un
quoi il était au palais de sports il est
sorti ils l'ont appelé ils l'ont dit
viens on va parler comme les adultes en
fait ils entraient dans un coin ils ont
plein axe secteur ils ont commencé à
taper l'envers la tête et c'est quoi
il m'a dit pas papa je l'entends je dis
qu'est ce qui est arrivé il m'a dit je
suis tombé si nécessaire de temps à 15
ans matri 82 et étampes comme un enfant
maudit où je suis tombé j'ai vu des
écoutes je comprends pas cette histoire
il ya quelque chose derrière je pense
après ils voulaient pas me parler moi je
voulais pas briser cette confiance de tu
me dis quelque chose moi je répétais à
tes parents il attendait pas grand chose
des adultes mais bien raconter c'est ce
qui s'est passé sa journée ou quoi mais
il voulait pas qu'on intervienne pour
lui il aimait bien se débrouiller tout
seul j'avais des rimes et amante esata
pas dit la vérité il a compris et quand
il a parlé et j'ai dit ok et maintenant
la solution c'est quoi il tenta parfois
des fois ils ont ouvert la tête 3 1
c'est quand la seleçao by men il avait
peur que son père est comme ça va
directement c'est pour ça et voilà nous
dans nos quartiers
voilà il n'ya pas il y en a un peu ce
truc de haguenau visite soixante et une
balance toi tu vas aller voir les
chemises hors de cause devant l'agent de
réflexion il ya pas un jeune qui à qui
tu vas voir tu as the way et lui taper
ce que tu allé porter plainte en a aucun
qui voit du roi je vais aller porter
plainte audio les 26 février 2021 c'est
les vacances scolaires et comme à son
habitude hayman rejoint ses amis au
centre d'animation de la grille la
dialectique sa map and i miss you call
it gdc il a délaissé un appel saveur
qu'un email à quelque chose à quoi
pascal bats pas tu pas c'est pourquoi je
dis répondu j'ai dit qu'est ce qui se
passe mais il n'y a rien de grave y'a
rien de méchant vous inquiétez pas je
peux vous dire que aymen il y à deux
passants qui l'ont tapé et j'ai laissé
que des personnels et de personnes c'est
qui est là par l'aiea ne s'en tient pas
là vidéo et j'ai compris en face est il
de même
j'ai vu altercation dimon la bagarre à
emmen qui tenait le grand coup sûr
entrer au centre à l'est mais ni la vie
et la ville visage rougi pouvoir ils
avaient peur ou sipa j'ai senti qu'il ya
un truc qui va pas
j'avais dit à irin qu est ce que tu
penses et devant la directrice et les
autres on va régler cette histoire soit
on va parler aux parents comme toi tu
connais la maman soit en voir la police
l'idée que ceux qui pensent on va aller
à voir la maman qui collait à maman m'a
dit oui ça allait vite ta les jeunes qui
n'étaient devant la porte royale d'un
ami papa il est sorti avec une barre en
métal dans les mains
voilà pourquoi il était donc plutôt dans
le contexte d'aller discuter avec lui
son frère il avait de satan dans ma tête
27 ans est un homme
on peut parler un peu discuté un peu
trop bien solution on peut régler
l'histoire entre leur a dit à amman il a
commencé à se reprocher et l'autre il a
pris une balle de ferraille il s'agit de
taper quoi il a je suis intervenu et
après il y avait
un coin bagarre entre nous pour demander
une petite minute coire après avoir sa
salle et ça allait super vite - j'étais
avec les jeunes de mon côté en train de
leur demander de rentrer chez eux ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas avoir tout ça je
peux au moment je suis revenu c'était
beaucoup plus loin dans la rue et c'est
encore en pleine altercation
voilà ma chambre arrive en courant tu as
legrand qui aviez je reviens dans 5
minutes disait pas et voilà
ensuite j'étais avec un iman est juste
en train de discuter avec lui je rentre
en voilà je tenterais demi mesure c'est
quoi cette histoire on s'en est venu aux
mains avec ton père et où tu vois là on
devrait rentrer dans la structure
attendait que ça se repose un peu tout
ça il va direct et ça l'a dit il faut
bien fermer la porte quoi et moi j'étais
avec mon pc face à face en train de
parler il m'a dit papa il m'a dit ça et
ça j'y le billet par il m'a dit il est
capable de tirer c'est à nous il me l'a
dit comme ça
j'avais mon collègue mamadou keita
gauche moi j'étais à droite aymen il est
en phase avec son père et le stun le
stagiaire a entendu le bruit c'est
n'importe quoi c'est quelqu'un qui sait
comme quelqu'un qui a essayé de tirer la
peur d'ouvrir la porte il a dit
l'actrice elle a dit oui c'est vrai il
faut pas ouvrir la porte
il a mis le pistolet c'est la faute de
la boîte à lettres là il attiré
l'intérêt un coût et il adore toucher
directement mon fils au thorax quoi on a
entendu la détonation
on a vu de la poudre la fumée blanche
avait l'odeur débuts voilà juste en
train de créer calmez vous calmez vous
c'est à blanc et tout va là parce que
j'avais jamais vu j'avais jamais eu à
faire une ré artistique c'est impossible
qu'un adulte du match et nation de
mafanco impossible que ce n'était pas un
scénario envisageable quand j'ai vu mon
fils il n'a pas parlé il a rien dit je
dis peut-être ses dix balles à blanc là
qu'on peut le tourner des films pour
jouer tout ça quoi et j'ai dit à sa main
c'était parce que c'est des balles à
blanc parce que je vois rien a lancé le
truc est alors envoyé mène un peu plus
en retirer sa doudoune sa sacoche se
poser lentement au sol et mon fils il
m'a dit papa est pas si mal moi j'ai
relevé la veste j'ai enlevé le tee shirt
et j'ai vu qu'il y avait celle au thorax
que tu n'as rien vu il y avait là tracy
la balle quoi j'essaie de le faire
parler voilà il reste avec moi j'avais
jamais eu affaire à ce genre de scénario
est jamais une 6 à l'arrivée du coup je
procède à un peu comme dans les films
muets reste avec moi serment la main par
le moi j'essaie tout ce que tout ce que
mozart on m'a dit de faire
ahmed le papa de aymen m'appelle en
catastrophe et j'entendais pas trop su
s'étaient brouillés y avait du goût
autour de lui et by women and men il est
par terre et des tombées au et puis
après midi bon écoute je laisse je suis
avec le samu
dépôt la police et pompiers
j'ai envoyé un message tellement courant
de l'état de santé de aymen s'il te
plaît j'espère que tout va rentrer dans
l'ordre crise
quand j'ai touché le visage avec la main
droite ils étaient 3 froide
oui et après il est gêné par les j'ai
parlé j'ai vu clair répond pas on est là
pour passer après ses bons surtout quand
il me dit ça il m'a dit m'a dit il ya
plein de sang à l'intérieur il mangeait
l'intermy ils n'arrêtent pas de respirer
j'ai compris que c'était trop tard ouais
mais répondu à 20h47 il est parti et
humaine il reviendra plus
aujourd'hui l'instruction est toujours
en cours et sociale et son grand frère
sont en détention provisoire à lesménils
partie des parts et pour moi c'est ça
fait très mal commencé c'est bizarre
même quand on rentre à la maison dix
fois j'ai franchement j'avais sa maman
derrière leurs fenêtres à vos gardes
c'est ça
si comme la dernière fois je les
entendais l'a dit
parce qu'elle était en train de parler
avec sa copine avait déjà tant aimé
qu'ils rentrent quoi
c'est ça
[Musique]
pachauri
c'est bizarre je suis je sais qu'il est
plus là mais dans un coin de ma tête
est encore là quoi j'essaie de
ne pas y penser voilà il ya des fois où
ça reste il ya des fois où ça rapporte
mais c'est compliqué à chasser ces
idées-là de la tête et j'ai deux jeunes
qui
qu'ils ont du mal
compliqué encore une fois
c'était important pour moi de vous
raconter l'histoire dahmane et commander
vidéo de bagarre qui se retrouvent sur
instagram ou des messageries peuvent
amener un brahms si ce reportage vous
intéressez laissez-moi des commentaires
j'y répondrai et si vous voulez voir
d'autres portages d'autres documentaires
c'est sur la page youtube de brut à
bientôt
[Musique]